well good evening everyone and welcome
to this
meeting of the
executive
uh on today the 10th of february 2022.
first of all any apologies for absence
and there are none we are all here
non-members attending
i can't see anyone sitting in the stalls
tonight so
no one there
and
to then take the
agenda item three minutes of the meeting
held on the 11th of january
are the minutes agreed members
thank you those are agreed
to move to item 4
are there any declarations of interest
council fd
for transparency item nine
i sometimes deliver stuff to one of the
country services
so it's very
convoluted and i sometimes do and i
sometimes don't and i've been advised
just to
advise you on transparency reasons
thank you councillor fd uh that is noted
questions on notice from councillors
there are none
which takes us nicely on to item seven
which is the quarter three twenty twenty
one
twenty two
oh i beg your pardon i'm getting way
ahead of myself item six mata's referred
to the executive reports from other
committees and um
there are none
can i go on to item seven now councillor
right that is the quarter three 20 21 22
financial management report um and to
introduce that report we'll turn to the
portfolio holder councillor simon smith
probably ably assisted by
naomi lukas thank you smith thank you
chairman um
as always the the
the size of the report that you see in
front of you and the detail
in it
gives a good indication of the
complexity of of the council finances
and as always um
it is naomi and her team that have put
this report together
i'm afraid as always some of the money
issues may sound a bit dry but i do have
a report which i'll i'll make a start on
so the purpose of the report
is to set out the forecast revenue and
capital position at quarter three
the latest revenue position is eleven
million seven hundred and thirty two
thousand pounds
changes to the original budget are due
to drawdowns from reserves which are
detailed in appendix one
the forecast outrun at quarter one is
eleven million one hundred and fifty
thousand pounds which gives a projected
underspend of five hundred and eighty
two thousand pounds after applying the
cove the council's covid19 general grant
allocation
and income
compensation funding
or just under five percent of the
revised budget
however without one off covered 19
funding the underspend would reduce to
175
73 000 pounds which equates to
1.5 percent of the revised budget
the variances across individual
portfolio budgets are set out in more
detail in the body of the report and at
appendix 2
but are mainly caused by higher than
forecast vacancy rates across the
council leading to underspends against
salary budgets
the council continues to feel the impact
of covert 19 on its budgets particularly
on car parking income which is currently
forecast to be 369
000 pounds under budget that's income
the council is required to report
regularly to government on its expected
financial pressures relating to the
pandemic
the 21 22 position will continue to be
closely monitored for the remainder of
the year and this has informed the
budget setting process for the coming 22
23 year and onwards
the original capital programme for 2122
was 3.6 million pounds
as part of the close down of the 2021
financial year 0.5 million pounds of
carry forwards were agreed creating a
revised budget of 4.1 million
the forecasted outrun on the council's
capital programme as at quarter 2
is
1.282 million
the major item of slippage against the
revised 2122 budget is the asset
development programme which accounts for
nearly 2 million pounds of the capital
budget this year
and this is pending agreement of the
first stop go decision point
the table at appendix 3 summarizes the
project projected capital position by
service area
in conclusion despite the significant
financial
challenges faced by the council during
21 22 due to good continued good
financial management we remain on track
to deliver the council's priorities
within the agreed budget this financial
year
thank you chairman
thank you very much council smith uh
naomi did you wish to add anything um no
okay um if i go around the table and
take any questions uh councillor has a
hand up
thank you chairman
uh refer to page 7.9 please
um
question for naomi
um
we have an election reserve fifteen
thousand pounds
and obviously we've got the unnecessary
cost of the by-elections that have been
called and not by the conservatives i
have hastened to add
where we're gonna have to run nine
polling stations all have to be manned
and of course to count in the evening
can you give me the anticipated cost for
that please
is it right to take that thanks and
yeah so sorry just to clarify the 15 000
pounds is not the totality of the
election smoothing reserve that's the
amount that has already been drawn down
this
financial year in relation to the
previous year's election but um yeah i
can
um obviously um provide a figure after
the coming election as to how much
that's cost in total
and once it's occurred
can i just
add to that answer
you are quite right councillor
if the election
had had not been called it would be an
additional cost not incurred within this
year but next thank you
thank you councillor smith are there any
other
questions
no i would just like to raise a couple
of points please um
i turn first of all to
7.19 and acknowledge the point that was
made
a little earlier um there is uh
absolutely no intention to
save money as a result of vacancies
and in fact i would go quite the other
way and it is this administration's
intention to fill vacancies as quickly
as is feasible
we recognize the stretch
in the officer team and whilst we
acknowledge the fact that when someone
resigns there is a period of time
from sometimes them leaving to the new
person being recruited
we want that to be absolutely minimal
because
we've seen enough stretch
in offices and it's this
administration's
clear and determined effort to make sure
that we don't
in any way capitalize on uh saving costs
through that that means
and the other point that i would like
clarification please on
is on
7.25
and i notice in terms of car parking
revenue um very very interesting table
list but i notice in relation to
webster's way
there's a negative 86
and two uh and i just wonder whether
you'd be kind enough just to help me
understand that very huge negative in
relation to webster's way
um yeah thank you councillor whitton
yeah and i
um concur that the it looks strange in
its presentation and the reason is an
accounting adjustment relating to the
covid um
19 sales fees and charges income
compensation scheme whereby the
government's provided some
additional grant income in the first
quarter but it wasn't actually received
in that quarter so what that's done is
um distorted to the
figures in quarter one and quarter three
um
it just yeah as i say through an
accounting adjustment so
i appreciate that doesn't give a
particularly clear view then of the
income relation to webster's way and
what i will do for the next quarter's
report is make sure that that um sort of
grant income is adjusted out so it gives
a clearer representation of the of the
figures so there is a reason for that
but i appreciate it's not particularly
clear the way that's shown at the moment
okay uh thank you naomi and if ever
there were a
very graphic
way of explaining actual income coming
in from uh car parking which is our
second largest income stream uh that
table shows it very very clearly and
what i do want to do is just really
build on the comment from councillor
smith uh i was at review along with
other executive members on tuesday a
very complex
complex report
from finance
tonight we have another report
and
we are in the budget season
this business as usual and
i've signed off this afternoon on the
council's governance statement which is
around financial issues and i really
would like to commend
naomi and her team
for the tremendous work that he's done
these reports don't come easily
and i think you and your team do an
absolutely splendid job uh and i really
do want to place that on public record
our appreciation to you and and and your
staff for that
and
we really appreciate that as a
executive team thank you naomi on that
now if i turn to
the decision being recommended at 1.1
and that is to note the quarter 3 20 21
22 revenue budget and capital position
set out in sections three and four below
and detailed in appendices one to five
uh members is that noted no joke
thank you very much indeed
we move on to agenda item eight which is
the section 106 quarterly briefing uh
for this month uh and uh uh i suspect
its councillor ian ward who will be
leading on that probably supported ably
by
marcus hoffman assistant director
thank you very much chairman
um yes the report is as it stands uh i
know that we have been wanting to
actually
see exactly what is happening with
section 106s and i think that's very
important as lots of members
have asked us in regards to their
residence what's being provided i think
it's very uh
important to note that on 3.3
the nhs or local ccg
for expenditure and a conversation i had
earlier with marcus
they are now i think this is
the south essex group is this not
south of mid essex this is a the group
that's been now newly formed are
actually looking
to use the money that we have
you know in our accounts
um we're currently holding uh on behalf
of the nhs
685
7715 and 48 pence
of money and we need that to be spent on
various things within our own unspent
account that we are in charge of
we have 494 000 we're i'll say 495
approximately it's over that amount
and that is being held also we have uh
250 000 which is going to be spent
um
for a games arena skate park in relation
to development of homes in holbridge
i think
the report
speaks for itself as what it is but i
would just like to make a note just
going forward
we must ensure that all large
developments that that come forward um
officers when considering the section
106 conditions should actively consult
with local members to discuss what
amenities and infrastructure will be
most appropriate for both local and new
residents and their respective needs and
ensure it can be delivered on the back
of any successful application i think
this is something that the
administration has really been pushing
for to ensure
that not only the new residents
get what they want from section 106 but
existing residents because of
the need because of the
i guess
there are
so many needs
in regards to the local population that
we need to take all those into
consideration but um i do commendary
paul and i i believe that marcus if
there are any in-depth questions on any
item within here
um
marcus or myself will be able to answer
it
thank you councillor ward and councillor
smith is
signaling with a question
i don't like to ask a question not about
what's in the report but what's not in
the report because the extent of section
106 money isn't is not
what's in the report there are obviously
contributions for schools that go to
essence county council
and highways ones
and to the lay person looking at this
report they may think that that is an
emission now it's not our money and it's
not held by us but i wonder if in future
there isn't somewhat some opportunity or
some format in which you could
further show the totality of section 106
money that's around i don't know how how
you'd do it and i certainly wouldn't
want to create
an amount of additional work but i think
it would be useful information
um both for members and the the wider
public
council award um i'm just going to
initially take that and i'm going to
pass it across to marcus um
we've been looking at where that money
goes for education there are lots of
issues in regards to that and how it is
used and when it's going to be used
we are constantly chasing essex who are
the main authority as far as that is
concerned
um
we
sometimes get an answer and sometimes we
don't
if i pass this across to marcus who will
probably be more specific on what is
actually happening
well
um
i suspect what you've asked for is is
possible uh moving forward rather than
looking back so you know i mean
respectfully if you said all is how many
years you wish to go back on on where
the contributions have gone but
certainly um i would have anticipated
it'd be fairly easiest for us to make a
note
of of those confusions coming in and
going back out to essex you know ledger
moving forward
and so they could be certainly put into
another sort of a appendage of this
report
thank you very much any more questions
council fd
thank you chairman um just two things
really
one it's not really
really to do with us
how difficult is to spend 106 money
especially
nhs i know of a parish councillors
bent my ear about
a local surgery and they want some money
but they've got a stump up a third
and
it's it seems to be very difficult if
they can't find that money to actually
get any others i know they've actually
had planning permission granted and it
is very difficult then for them to
actually do that is there any way
maybe
talking to
how this is done especially the nhs i
don't really know
well as far as as far as i understand um
if they are surgeries private surgeries
which they are
um
they are a private business
and in most cases from what i understand
and what i have been told by those
businesses is they have to put up at
least 50 percent
to get
the other remaining amount so
those people
clinicians who are there the partners
they actually have to put their hand in
their pockets to get 50 of the required
amount and then the money comes forward
that is that is what i've been told um
with two specific surgeries in regards
to to that as they are private
okay thank you and just one other
question uh we've got uh starlain
brickworks where there's like a money
for a mug and i know
last few years we've been trying to
spend that money and again it's very
difficult
and i think we're
six years into this we've got to give it
back in another
maths nine years
so
i think i think is any way we can spend
this money well so i don't want to give
it back to the developer no no i i think
um again i'm going to pass it over to
marcus because marcus has actually been
having a conversation in regards to this
particular item
thank you so much it is um scheduled to
be to um have some work done if you
remember we've also got the play space
improvement program where um um this
authority puts aside capital for for
work so um there is a scheme to to uh to
invest about a hundred thousand in a
mugger for great wakering
and so the contribution is
going to be used as part of that um
monies um so the the delay has really
just been due to covered frankly
so there's been a general delay in the
play space program and but we do
anticipate wrong in the next couple of
years so yes it will be done that's
excellent thank you marcus
any more questions members
okay um
certainly i really welcome this report
and it was me that actually uh asked um
a year or so ago uh for us to understand
what section 106 monies were um were
they and have some sort of report so
thank you marcus and the team again for
putting that together
i certainly
bring out councillor ward's point there
is a significant amount of money um
which actually is waiting to be invested
in watchmen over a million pound
and
we need to get on and spend it i realize
it's scheduled for spend but there can't
be complacency because this is what 106
money is all about
and some of these dates sort of look a
long way ahead
but certainly we don't want to run out
of time
the last thing we would ever want to do
is give it back
but i do fear there's further work that
needs to be done just to make sure that
the appropriate authorities and i'm
especially talking about the nhs here
are aware that this money and and get on
and spend it and improve you know we we
talk about patient waiting lists we talk
about facilities for the nhs and there
should be a joined up approach
to
get that authority to work with us
so
so i i make that point the other point
that i would like to make about 106 is i
do
urge there to be member engagement at
the time 106 monies are
agreed and that's starting to happen
because i think it's really important
with developments that money is focused
into
real community needs
rather than treating 106 as a tick the
box exercise and really what the
developer says
there should be true engagement with
members and officers at the outset and i
think that's the next stage in this 106
process not only to know what we've got
in the pot but actually to know
where we want to direct this money
towards because quite rightly we hear
from residents they want to talk about
infrastructure
we agree with them infrastructure first
but this is a wonderful opportunity to
spend significant amounts of money to
improve infrastructure
and certainly the lives of our residents
council award you may be indicating you
want to come back i did indeed
i think with uh the new group new nhs
group that we've been talking to
there is a great deal of positivity and
understanding of the money that is held
on their behalf by rochford and they are
very very anxious to try and draw down
on that money to use it locally and
that's an ongoing positive conversation
so that is a good step forward that we
have
thank you council award
no other points in that case i will turn
to
the
recommendation at 1.1 that the position
on unspent section 106 contributions
held by the council as at the 1st of
january
2022 be noted is that noted members
thank you
we move on to
item
nine on the agenda and that
is the process for awarding voluntary
sector grants
for the fourth coming year
and my turn to
the portfolio holder for community
arthur williams council arthur williams
to introduce the report please
thank you chairman
doesn't the year go quickly we're here
again um
thank you yeah this this
this report is is more or less
self-explanatory it enables us to
continue doing the the excellent work
that the voluntary groups do in our area
so
without further ado i would like to
offer this report
thank you
thank you very much uh members any
questions on as councillor williams says
a um a uh pretty thorough and
self-explanatory report councillor webb
thank you chairman i'd just like to draw
members attention to uh 3.6 which
outlines the previous work that was
carried out for the voluntary sector
grant and you'll notice that there are
11 awards that were given out last year
um supporting so many different
organizations within the district
and that's actually outlined in table a
and we can see that we're not just
giving money away for the fun of it
actually this money is making a
significant difference in our
communities and i think we should be
very proud as a district we still offer
this support to our voluntary sector a
number of authorities don't do that we
still do that and i think that
particularly for me table 8 highlights
why we need to do that
and excellent work that is going on
within our communities thank you
chairman
council webb you make a really important
point and i totally agree i'm proud to
be part of an authority which
whilst it's facing the financial
challenges that are upon us we are still
able to run schemes like this
and
you make a valuable point that this
administration will be committed to
now and in the future
however else we
find the stretch financially difficult
we've always got to remember the
importance of investing in our voluntary
sector and supporting them
council williams you wish to come back
yeah thank you chairman the yeah thank
you councillor but i do agree with you
and especially during the
very difficult year that we've had and
uh the static that i can't say the word
the statistics in this are quite amazing
considering what we've had to go through
so yeah thank you very much thank you
thank you council williams
right if there's no other
questions or comments um again i'll turn
to um
1.1 um and 1.2 and 1.3 for taking him in
turn
um 1.1 to put in place a procedure for
allocating the voluntary sector grants
fund for the financial year 2022-23
is that agreed
1.2 to agree that this process remains
clear and transparent whilst aligning
outcomes with those identified in the
rockford district council
business plan relating to partnership
working and links to the joint rochford
and castle point health and wellbeing
strategy for 22
2022 to 2025
is that agreed members
thank you
and finally 1.3 to agree that
rady rochford and district association
for voluntary services ravs
will receive top sliced funding from the
same pot based on outcomes aligned with
the essex county council performance
framework and the hwbs action plan is
that agreed members
thank you very much uh at um
four minutes to eight uh this evening
that uh concludes the meeting thank you
very much indeed for your attendance and
at that point i will close the meeting
thank you very much